- Beauty products have
been around forever,
but how long?
How did it all start?
For example, the red lip.
What is the origin and history
of one of beauty's most
important products?
I love this, take a look.
(upbeat music)
The history of red
lipstick can be traced back
almost 5,000 years.
Ancient Sumerians made
the world's first lipstick
out of crushed gemstones and white lead.
Rumor has it that Egyptian
Pharaoh, Cleopatra
made hers from flowers, fish
scales and crushed ants.
That gives a new meaning
to all natural ingredients,
doesn't it?
Elizabeth the First
believed that a red lip
had magical powers to
heal and ward off danger,
which is darkly ironic since
most lipstick and makeups
were made of poisonous lead.
Flash forward to the early 20th century
when a bold red lip was seen as shocking.
In New York City, suffragettes
took to the streets,
campaigning for the vote,
wearing a red lip to
symbolize the new woman.
In the 30s, Vogue declared
lipstick the most important
cosmetics for women and sales skyrocketed.
During World War II,
a red lip became the symbol of patriotism
and feminine resilience.
The US government ordered
war factory dressing rooms
to be stocked with lipstick
to boost female workers'
efficiency and morale.
That's my kind of government mandate.
Today. the red lips is still
seen as a symbol of power,
sexiness and feminine rebellion.
As Coco Chanel once said,
"If you are sad, add more
lipstick and attack."
Well, that's a lot of history for a little
(kisses)
rouge on the lips?
Okay, now what do you need
to execute this iconic,
iconic beauty look?
Okay, it's really quite simple.
You need a good lip liner,
especially when you get a little older.
That's right.
It really brings out your
inner ReeRee or Marilyn.
I didn't need lip liner when I was younger
but now I certainly do.
And this lip liner is by Lip Bar
and this is a fantastic
lip liner right here,
like highly recommended.
And so I'm gonna just do
my lip liner real quick.
And then I think one of the biggest
and most important reds in
the history of red lipstick
is the Mac Russian Red.
This is the one that Madonna made popular
in the 90s and you could not get it.
It was completely sold out everywhere.
So I hold this as the
benchmark to all red lipsticks.
Now I'm going to put on a Flower Beauty.
This component is really cool
'cause it's double ended.
Uh-huh and this is called Red Velvet
because it reminds me of cake.
Uh-huh, thank you, Arturo.
(audience cheers and applauds)
Mm hmm.
And what's really cool
is the other component
has a little lip gloss on the other side.
It's funny.
You know, when women put on a red lip,
it like changes their demeanor
and some people call it
the high heel of makeup.
So if there's a little tool that you have
that can change your demeanor
and have a little light bulb in your face,
then I say, turn on the red light.
(upbeat music)